[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend wir haben dieses
Jahr begonnen mit einem furchtbaren
Krieg der uns in Atem hält wir beenden
dieses Jahr mit zwei furchtbaren kriegen
und kein Ende in sicht weder in der
Ukraine noch in Nahost dort will Israel
trotz internationale Appelle und immer
mehr Toten seine Offensive im
Gazastreifen ausweiten und die
Terroristen von Hamas ergehen sich in
Durchhalteparolen derweil ist das Leid
der Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza nur noch
schwer in Worte zu fassen die Warnungen
vor Hungersnot und solen sind nicht mehr
zu
überhören kann das so weitergehen
welche Perspektiven gibt es darüber
reden wir gleich erst die aktuelle Lage
von Susanna Santina aus Tel
Aviv verzweifelt halten Sie Ihren
Ausweis hoch nur wenn Sie registriert
sind haben sie überhaupt eine Chance auf
Hilfslieferungen in Raffa im Süden Gazas
sind in den letzten Tagen dutzende LKW
mit Lebensmittelpaketen angekommen
darauf hat auch hitam alaidi
gehofft es wird viel gestohlen Seiten
ich oh Erol her die Vertriebenen gehen
oft leer aus die Hilfe kriegen meistens
andere immer wieder hören wir dass Hamas
Leute viele Hilfsgüter mitnehmen vor der
Kamera sagen will es uns aber keiner
klar ist die Hilfe reicht nicht für alle
ein Grund dafür ist für die israelische
Regierung
klar leider funktioniert die Hilfe der
UN in Gaza nicht weil sie über die
Organisation unra
läuft Menschen die Hilfe brauchen
kriegen sie nicht weil Hamas vieles
abgreift und die unra das deckt ein
nicht nur von Israel erhobener Vorwurf
den die Hilfsorganisation immer wieder
zurückweist in Gaza gehen die
israelischen Angriffe unverändert weiter
im Süden ist vor allem hanjunis unter
Beschuss weil die israelische Armee sagt
es se eine Hochburg der
hamasterroristen und präsentiert einen
weiteren tunnelschacht direkt in einer
Moschee dieser hier sei in der Nähe
eines Krankenhauses und einer Schule in
der Gaza Stadt entdeckt worden darin
dutzen en Patronen Handgranaten
sprengmaterial israel fühlt sich
bestätigt wir müssen noch stärker werden
die Kämpfe werden kraftvoller und tiefer
sein und Sie werden Überraschungen
Bergen schon jetzt leiden vor allem die
Zivilisten wie hier in
hanunes von 200 Toten in Gaza innerhalb
von 24 Stunden spricht die von der Hamas
krlierte
[Musik]
Gesundheitsbehörde wenigen noch
funktionierenden Krankenhäuser Arbeiten
am
[Musik]
Limit wir saßen gerade beim Essen als
die Bombe auf unser Haus fiel wir haben
mit der Hamas doch nichts zu tun ich
wünschte wir wären in Gaza Stadt
geblieben und nicht nach hanjunis
geflohen wir sind nirgends
sicher und für die Menschen Israel wird
die Gefahr aus dem Norden immer größer
wegen der zunehmenden Angriffe der vom
Iran unterstützen hisbolla Milizen
wurden die Soldaten an der Grenze zum
Libanon in erhöhte Alarmbereitschaft
versetzt aus dieser libanesischen
Moschee sollen Raketen auf Israel
gefeuert worden
sein und dieser hisbolla Führer droht
wir fürchten weder Israel noch
[Musik]
Amerika die Zeit für eine politische
Lösung läuft ab wenn die Welt und die
libanesische Regierung nicht handeln um
die Angriffe zu beenden wird unser
Militär
reagieren ein Ende des Krieg ist nach
fast D Monaten in weiter
Ferne derostexperte Daniel Gerlach ist
bei uns Chefredakteur des Fachmagazins
Zenit Daniel Gerlach guten Abend und
willkommen zurück im heutejournal ja
guten Abend vielen Dank im Nahen Osten
gibt's immer mehrere Seiten einer
Geschichte heißt das es gibt hinter
diesen markigen Parolen auch dann doch
so etwas wie Bewegung es gibt
Verhandlungen natürlich aus Qatar ist zu
hören dass der Chef des israelischen
Auslandsgeheimdienstes Mossad wieder mit
den spricht die Ägypter haben es
versucht sie haben heute auch bekannt
gegeben dass sie einen Plan vorgelegt
haben der aber weder von der Hamas noch
von der israelischen Seite bisher
beantwortet wurde also es passiert was
im Hintergrund das Problem ist nur diese
Verhandlung die können technische Fragen
klären aber sie können letztendlich
nicht die politische Entscheidung
ersetzen und was notwendig ist um eine
Feuerpause zu erringen ist eine
politische Entscheidung und die Ägypter
haben z.B vorgeschlagen dass man die so
stufenweise einführen könnte und dass
man erstmal zwei Wochen lang die Waffen
schweigen lässt und solche feuerp sind
nicht nur wie wir jetzt gerade gesehen
haben aus humanitären Gründen
unersässlich sondern auch aus
politischen Gründen denn die Zeit läuft
ab dass man überhaupt noch ein Szenario
entwickeln kann wie man die Zukunft von
Gaza politisch gestaltet und ob man
überhaupt noch jemanden findet der daran
teilnehmen möchte das wird nicht
passieren wenn wenn in Gaza nichts mehr
nichts mehr wieder aufzubauen ist
politische Entscheidung ist das
interessante Stichwort ich erinnere mich
an ein Gespräch mit dem ehemaligen
israelischen Ministerpräsidenten Ehud
Barak der hat gesagt damals dass
Benjamin Netanyahu wenn auch
unterbewusst im Zweifel immer eine
Entscheidung treffen wird die den Krieg
eher verlängert einfach weil ihm ein
längerer Krieg in die Hände Spiele ist
das auch ein Grund wesalb es von
Netanyahu immer wieder heißt wir hören
nicht auf ich glaube nicht dass es der
einzige Grund ist ich denke der Gedanke
an seine Karriere und an seine Zukunft
schwingt hier mit aber es ist für ihn
auch ein schicksalhafter Moment wir
dürfen nicht vergessen sein eigener
Bruder ist ein Held gewesen der 19 1976
bei einer Geiselbefreiung einer
spektakulären Geiselbefreiung ums Leben
gekommen ist er war der israelische Held
der die Stärke Israels im Ausland
irgendwie auch immer gezeigt hat und
Netanyahu ist jetzt in einer solchen
Situation dass er Geisel nach Hause
bringen soll aber nicht weiß wie
gleichzeitig sich auf ganz andere
Kriegsziele konzentriert wie an den
Palästinensern an der palästinensischen
Bevölkerung in Gaza letztendlich
Vergeltung zu üben das Thema Geisel ist
in den letzten Tagen komplett in den
Hintergrund gerückt und jetzt wird es
eben wieder Zeit dass das in den
Vordergrund rückt die Frage ist nur sind
diese Geiseln noch im Leben hat die
Hamas Zugriff auf sie und wer kann sie
dazu bewegen tatsächlich die Geisel
freiulassen die palästinensische Seite
rechnet nach meinem Eindruck nicht damit
dass der Krieg vorbei sein wird wenn man
die Geiseln freiässt sondern man geht
davon aus dass diese Operation
weitergeht und man weiß nicht bis wohin
sie geführt wird wie lange kann denn
Hamas eigentlich noch weitermachen man
müsste doch mittlerweile annehmen dass
deren Kommandostrukturen weitgehend
zerstört sein sollten oder diese Frage
kann ich nicht beantworten und ich finde
sie auch rätselhaft denn auf der einen
Seite ist es so man sieht die
unglaubliche Zerstörung die die
israelischen Operationen dort
angerichtet haben man hört ja auch dass
die Israelis äh
sagen sie wissen wo Hamas sich befindet
und trotzdem hat jetzt gerade erst der
der militärische Chef der Hamas im
Gazastreifen jahwar wieder eine
Stellungnahme abgegeben hat
Durchhalteparolen verkündet also es
scheint offensichtlich noch eine
Struktur zu geben und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass vor diesem Krieg
die Stärke der Hamas auf ungefähr 30.000
Mann geschätzt wurde die nur den
militärischen und Sicherheitsbereich
betreffen nicht die anderen die da noch
mitgearbeitet haben insofern ist das
eine große Kraft und sie scheint äh sich
auf eine solche Situation vorbereitet zu
haben wir müssen gleich noch kurz über
die Lage an der Nordgrenze Israels zum
Libanon reden aber erst noch schnell zum
Thema Amerika wir hören mahnende Worte
Richtung des Verbündeten aus dem Weißen
Haus von Präsident Biden wir hören den
Außenminister blinken
aber eben es sind nur Worte ist es denn
so dass der US-Präsident diesen Krieg
beenden könnte wenn er nur wollte wenn
er nur wirklich wollte ich denke die
Amerikaner haben viel Macht das zu tun
aber
die Instrumente sind das Problem denn
wenn der Präsident wirklich maximalen
Druck auf die die Regierung Netanyahu
ausüben möchte dann wird er da auch
Widerstand bei im eigenen Haus also im
Kongress treffen und die Frage ist
möchte einen solchen innenpolitischen
Konflikt riskieren gleichzeitig weiß er
und sieht er dass seine Haltung die als
passiv empfunden wird die einen sagen er
war nicht stark genug an Israels Seite
die anderen sagen er war an Israels
Seite und hat im Grunde nichts getan um
dieses diese Katastrophe zu verhindern
dass diese Situation dazu führen kann
dass er die Wahl verliert dass sie ihm
wirklich diesen Wahlkampf verhagelt und
das ist eine Situation manche
israelische experten vergleichen dass
mit der suiskrise von 1956 also dass die
lange nicht mehr da gewesen ist dass die
Amerikaner vor der Wahl stehen auß dem
politische Ziele aufgeben zu müssen und
große Verluste auch zu erleiden
weil sie eben nichts tun um Israel unter
Druck zu setzen er kann das tun aber
dafür müsste er einen höheren Preis
bezahlen der eben auch innenpolitisch
ist dramatische Situation auch in den
USA ganz kurz noch wie angekündigt wie
gefährlich ist die Situation aktuell an
Israels Nordgrenze
im im zusammenhanghang mit der Hisbollah
dort
ich halte die Situation für sehr
gefährlich die hisbolla ist nicht die
Hamas und sie hat auch noch andere
Optionen als Krieg gegen Israel zu
führen und sie weiß dass ein ein ein ein
Krieg zu ihrem Schaden sein wird auf der
anderen Seite hat sie um die 150.000
Raketen und eine neue Situation denn
Israelis gehen jetzt davon aus dass und
das hat der 7 Oktober gezeigt wer wer
die das Potenzial hat sie anzugreifen
wird das tun und deswegen werden sie
versuchen einem solchen Schlag
zuvorzukommen und das ist die große
Gefahr sie werden vielleicht nutzen
wollen dass die amerikanischen
Flugzeugträger noch im östlichen
Mittelmeer sind dass vielleicht die
Amerikaner sie dann noch unterstützen
werden eine Situation die Sie vielleicht
später nicht mehr haben werden und
deswegen halte ich die Situation für
sehr gefährlich und das hat der
israelische also Mitglied des
kriegskabinetts Benny ganz gerade auch
erst gestern gesagt Daniel gler
herzlichen Dank auch heute Abend wieder
für ihre Expertise vielen Dank ja danke
auch und damit in dieser Sendung zu uns
nach Deutschland wie man Feuerwehrleute
im Einsatz die uns alle Schützen
angreifen kann das sollte eigentlich
jedem komplett unbegreiflich sein und
eigentlich sollte niemand Appelle
benötigen das bitte nicht zu tun
eigentlich sollten wir hier in
Deutschland nicht über härtere Strafen
diskutieren müssen angesichts Hunderter
eben solcher Angriffe eigentlich
andererseit ist bald Silvester und
verbunden damit besonders schlechte
Erfahrungen Ksten Berend aus
Berlin Feuerwehrmann Baris schoban ist
einiges gewöhnt von Rettungseinsätzen in
berlinneuköln do die silvesternach 2022
war härter aggressiver lebensgefährlich
Polizisten und Rettungskräfte wurden zu
Zielscheiben wir wurden halt in diese ja
Hinterhalte gelockt wir wurden zum
Aussteigen regelrecht gezwungen und in
dem Moment als wir ausgestiegen sind
gingen die Angriffe halt nicht nur gegen
unser Fahrzeug sondern auch gegen uns
als Einsatzkräfte und Menschen und das
war halt anders als in den Jahren zuvor
was folgte war ein Feuerwerk
Anforderungen das nicht umgesetzt wurde
und nun wieder auf lodert mehr Polizei
härtere Strafen und ein
deutschlandweites
böllerverbot wir müssen nicht
betrunkenen Menschen Böller Kugelblitze
oder andere Sprengstoffe in die Hand
geben die die Notaufnahmen füllen die
Unbeteiligte verletzen und die dazu
genutzt werden um absichtlich geplant
Polizistinnen und Polizisten in den
Dienstfahrzeugen oder in der
Schutzausrüstung anzugreifen doch wie
alle Jahre wieder läuft seit heute der
Verkauf für ein generelles böllerverbot
es einen Konsens von Bund und Ländern
aber den gibt es nicht so kann private
Knallerei nur lokal begrenzt verboten
werden in Berlin in diesem Jahr an vier
Orten erstmals auch rund um die
Sonnenallee in Neuköln wo es im Vorjahr
besonders heftig zuging ich habe ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen Angst weil ich
vermute dass es genau wieder so laufen
wird wie im letzten Jahr auch wenn
Böller Verbot ist ich meine da kann ja
Spaß haben und knallen aber
bisschenutsamer die Sache im
Gaza zusammenhängt dann wird es glaube
ich schlimmer hier die Befürchtung der
Krieg in narost könnte die Stimmung
zusätzlich anheizen Berlins Polizei geht
mit einem rekordaufgebot von insgesamt
4000 Beamten in die Silvesternacht die
Strategie Rettungskräfte begleiten bei
Straftaten konsequent einschreiten und
Täter beweissicher Filmen wir werden mit
bodycamps ausgestattet sein und last but
not least kann es auch sein dass waer
Wasserwerfer zum Einsatz kommen die auch
im letzten Jahr einerseits gelöscht
haben die wir aber tatsächlich auch so
stationiert haben dass sie zum Einsatz
kommen könnten Feuerwehrmann Baris
schobah sagt er rechne mit dem
Schlimmsten aber er hoffe auf das beste
wir müssen irgendwie versuchen den
Menschen da draußen mehr zu zeigen
Mensch da steckt auch ein Mensch hinter
dieser Uniform der auch eine Familie
vielleicht zu Hause hat und einfach nur
seinen Job versehen möchte und so macht
er mit in einem Social Media Video von
Polizei und Feuerwehr greift uns nicht
an schießt uns nicht mit Böllern Raketen
oder schreckschus waen ihr macht euch
strafbar und euch drohen mehrere Jahre
Gefängnis es ist ein Appell an den
gesunden
Menschenverstand ja fragen zum Thema
noch an den Vorsitzenden der
Gewerkschaft der Polizei nachher bei uns
im heute journal Update jetzt erstmal
weitere Nachrichten hier mit dir Hanna
und da geht der Blick auf die
Pegelstände ja auch heute blieb die
Hochwasserlagen Teilen von Ost und
Norddeutschland kritisch alleine
Niedersachsen sind laut
Ministerpräsident weil mehr als 100.000
Menschen gegen die Fluten im Einsatz in
Winsen an der alla mussten rund 300
Bewohner ihre Häuser verlassen in
SachsenAnhalt wurde erstmals seit der
Jahrhundertflut 2013 das przina wer
geöffnet um so rund ein Drittel des
elbwassers an Magdeburg und an anderen
Orten vorbeizuleiten betroffen ist auch
der Serien geti Park im
niedersächsischen Hodenhagen wegen der
Überflutungen müssen Teile des gel
evakuiert
werden die Sanktionen für
bürgergeldempfänger die jegliche
Jobangebote ablehnen sollen deutschlich
verschärft werden ein Gesetzentwurf von
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil sieht vor
dass Leistungsempfängern in diesem Fall
für zwei Monate das komplette Bürgergeld
gestrichen werden kann die Kosten für
Wohnung und Heizung werden weitergezahlt
bisher kann das Bürgergeld um maximal
30% gekürzt
werden der Bund zichtet auf eine Klage
gegen exverkehrsminister scheuer wegen
der hohen Kosten der gescheiterten
pkwmaut damit folgt das
Bundesverkehrsministerium einem
Gutachten das aufgrund geringer
Erfolgsaussichten von juristischen
Schritten abrätt die pkwmaut war 2019
vom Europäischen Gerichtshof gestoppt
worden zuvor hatte schuer jedoch bereits
Verträge mit vorgesehenen Betreibern
geschlossen an diese musste der Bund
243 Millionen Euro Schadensersatz zahlen
die Ukraine hat von den USA die wohl
vorerst letzte umfangreiche Militärhilfe
in Höhe von 250 Millionen Dollar
erhalten das Paket umfasst unter anderem
Luftabwehr und
Artilleriemunition mit diesem Schritt
dürften die bisher bewilligten us-mittel
ausgeschöpft sein weitere ukrainehilfen
waren zuletzt von den Republikanern im
uskongress blockiert
worden im Weltall haben die USA und
Russland ihre Zusammenarbeit verlängert
das teilte die russische
Raumfahrtbehörde Ros Kosmos mit konkret
geht es um gemeinsame Flüge zur
Internationalen Raumstation is zuletzt
hatte es einen solchen Flug im September
gegeben bis Ende 20125 soll das nun
weitergehen russland hatte eigentlich
angekündigt die Kooperation Ende 2024
einzustellen und sich auf den Bau einer
eigenen Raumstation zu
konzentrieren ja über denri Kriege in
der Ukraine haben wir in dieser Sendung
schon kurz gehört wir berichten seit
fast zi Jahren regelmäßig darüber über
frontverläufe über Erfolge und
gegenoffensiven über unendlich viel Leid
heute geht es um das Leben inmitten von
so viel Tod die Ukraine hatte schon vor
dem Krieg eine der niedrigsten
Geburtenraten dieser Welt verglichen mit
vor dem Krieg ist sie jetzt noch mal um
28% gefallen bei weitem zu wenig um die
Bevölkerungszahl auch nur annähernd
stabil zu halten wenn gerade im Osten
des Landes ein Kind zur Welt kommt dann
ist das wie überall sonst biologischer
Alltag und gleichzeitig ein Wunder es
ist dort auch wie unsere Reporterin
Alisa jung sagt etwas was demütig macht
sie berichtet aus dem einzigen
Krankenhaus im Ukrainisch kontrollierten
Teil des Donbass das in der Lage ist
auch Frühchen zu versorgen
hier beginnt ihr Start ins Leben Milana
kommt per Kaiserschnitt im Krankenhaus
von provs zur Welt mitten im Krieg nur
40 km entfernt von der Frontlinie trotz
mehrfacher Raketenangriffe auf die Stadt
haben sie hier nie aufgehört zu arbeiten
Olena jchenko ist die oberste Hebamme
arbeitet seit 37 Jahren hier weglaufen
war für sie keine
Option das war Angst um dein Leben um
das Leben der Kinder man tun wohin soll
man laufen aber die Vernunft und der
Menschenverstand haben das überwunden
wir mussten uns beruhigen die Situation
akzeptieren und wieder arbeiten um den
Frauen zu
helfen besonders auch den Frauen deren
Babys zu früh geboren werden und die
ohne die Hilfe der ärztinen und
Schwestern kaum überleben würden basa
sie ist 6 Tage alt und sollte noch gar
nicht auf dieser Welt sein bei der
Geburt nur
seit der russischen Invasion werden mehr
Babys zu früh
geboren seitdem sind bei uns insgesamt
654 Kinder zur Welt gekommen davon 68
Frühgeborene das heißt fast ein zehel
von allen Babys sind
frühgeburen schwanger während die Region
mit Raketen und drohen beschossen
wird wenn die Frauen eine Explosion oder
ein lautes Geräusch hören bekommen Sie
natürlich
Angst hier eingeliefert dann ist es
logisch die Frau ist gestresst und
bekommt
Schmerzen wenn Sie hier ankommt
versuchen wir die Schwangerschaft
aufrecht
zuuerhalten doch das klappt nicht immer
die Frühchen im Inkubator brauchen Ruhe
Wärme und Dunkelheit ihre ersten Wochen
Kosten schon so viel Kraft wenn hier der
raketenalarm ertönt bleibt den Frauen
nur Schutz auf dem Flur zu suchen weg
von den
Fenstern zwei Wände nach außen denn wir
können nicht alle sozusagen unter die
Arme nehmen und nach unten in den Bunker
Rennen viermal gab es schon kein Strom
und kein Wasser mit Generatoren und
eigenem Brunnen schützen sie sich nun
davor Nadja kraftchenko will dem Leib
mit Leben trotzen vor dii Tagen brachte
sie Varvara zur Welt will sich ihr Glück
und die Zuversicht nicht nehmen
lassen alle hier in der Region sind sehr
besorgt aber das Leben muss
weitergehen sie sagt aus großer Liebe
werden glückliche Kinder
geboren was für ein wundervoller Satz so
jetzt noch mal du Hanna ja und da
blicken wir abermals auf eine Pleite
meldung vom Immobilien und
Handelsimperium des Milliardärs ren
Benko heute wurde bekannt dass ein
weiteres Signer Unternehmen Insolvenz
angemeldet hat und zwar ein durchaus
bedeutendes zu Z dem Immobilien in den
absoluten Toplagen Deutschlands gehören
Valerie Haller was bedeutet das genau ja
genau sign Prime das ist sozusagen das
Herzstück des Firmen Imperium signa
Prime baut und vermietet Immobilien und
ist unter Druck geraten wegen hoher Bau
und Finanzierungskosten die sinertochter
will sich nun massiv gesund schrumpfen
und den Immobilienbestand weitgehend
verkaufen ja und zu signner Prime
gehören Bauvorhaben wie der Hamburger
elbtwerer und 54 sich teils prominente
Adressen wie das ebenfalls in der Hans
stattbefindliche Alsterhaus und das KDW
in Berlin schon einige siner Töchter
haben in den vergangenen Wochen
Insolvenz angemeldet darunter auch die
Holding ja und morgen dürfte dann noch
die signner development folgen ein
Projektentwickler auch die Immobilien
von Galleria karstadtkaufhof gehören zu
insolventen Signer Prime inwiefern wird
sich das jetzt auf die Kette auswirken
das noch nicht ganz klar dürfte aber
nicht ohne Folgen bleiben Galeria ist ja
nicht nur Mieter von signner sondern
gehört seit einigen Jahren auch zur
Gruppe und sollte eigentlich eine
kräftige Finanzspritze bekommen ob das
Geld jetzt fließt ist angesichts der
schwierigen Lage der sinergruppe
fraglich bei Galleria jedoch wird das
Geld langsam knapp Medien berichten dass
die Kaufhauskette eine Insolvenz prüft
das wäre dann die dritte innerhalb
weniger Jahre vielen Dank Valerie für
diese
Einordnungen am zweiten Tag der
bundesweiten praxisschließungen hat sich
der Ton zwischen den Verbänden und
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
verschärft Lauterbach kritisierte die
Streiks im ZDF und wandte sich deutlich
gegen höhere Honorare der Vorsitzende
des wirchob Bundes Heinrich der die
niedergelassenen Ärzte vertritt betonte
es ginge nicht um die Steigerung von
arzteinkommen sondern um die
ausreichende Finanzierung bestehender
Strukturen sie seien akut gefährdet am 9
Januar soll ein Krisentreffen
stattfinden
kommunale Gebühren und Abgaben wie etwa
Grund und Gewerbesteuer könnten im
nächsten Jahr steigen davon geht der
Haupt der Geschäftsführer des Städte und
Gemeindebundes Landsberg aus Grund sei
etwa die hohe Inflation der Präsident
des Deutschen landkreistags Saga
forderte eine andere Finanzverteilung
zwischen bundländern und Kommunen 25%
der Ausgaben des öffentlichen Haushalts
lägen bei den Kommunen aber nur 14 pro
des Steueraufkommens das müsse
korrigiert werden so Saga gegenüber dem
Handelsblatt morgen wird die 72
vierschancenourer eröffnet und nach der
heutigen Qualifikation in Oberdorf sieht
es für die deutschen Skispringer
durchaus gut aus gleich fünf von ihnen
haben es unter die ersten 12 Plätze
geschafft allen voran Olympiasieger
Andreas Wellinger auf Platz 1 mit
135 m nur einen Meter vor dem
zweitplatzierten Karl
Geiger und jetzt gibt's etwas zum
Hinhören im Fernsehen eine Stimme die
sich unmittelbar einbrennt die berühmte
reine Stimme Glocken Klara Sopran in
schwindelerregenden Höhen damit ist John
B berühmt geworden und die Stimme hat
ihr Leben geprägt eine unfassbare
Achterbahnfahrt aus karrierehighlights
und Selbstzweifeln Erfolg und Depression
gefeiert werden und Therapiesitzungen
all das hat die Stimme mitmachen müssen
und auch danach klingt sie jetzt in
einem neuen Kinofilm in dem John B auf
ihr Leben blickt mit 82 was für ein
Leben Claudio
[Musik]
Armbruster
201 Vorbereitung für die abschiedsturnee
joh ist Ende 70 und kämpft um ihre
Stimme manche Noten brauchen mehr
Vibrato so habe ich mehr
Zeit diese Töne will ich
aussingen Bob Dylan beobachtet die Szene
aus seinem gem herus und kamerasobachten
sie für
diesenkum das gefunden ich denke in
meiner
Vergangenheit ihre Vergangenheit war die
große Zeit der folk music in
Amerika ich habe es bis hierher
geschafft also singe ich einfach was ich
gern singen möchte ich habe das Gefühl
zu explodieren und das tue
[Musik]
ich auch immer ich war die richtige
Stimme zum richtigen Zeitpunkt das
katapultierte mich in eine neue
Stratosphäre diese Zeit Anfang der 60er
in der sie ein Star
[Musik]
wurde die Zeit des gewaltfreien protests
in der sie eine der Hauptfiguren
[Musik]
war
ten ich war berauscht von seinem
Talent sie machte ihn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
berühmt dann als er berühmt war ließ er
sie
fallen
es war ein Gefühl totaler
Demoralisierung ich war völlig
demoralisiert es war
schrecklich
Bob hat mir das Herz
gebrochen doch das waren nur Jahre ihres
Lebens derilm erähtel
mehr er zählte Geschichten von ihren
Dämonen ihren psychischen Problemen die
sie seit ihrer Kindheit begleiten
derpressionen Angst und Panikattacken
Psychopharmaka ihr Leben lang und er
erzählt von
Missbrauch der Film kommt ihr so nahe
dass es weh
tut eine bewegende Biografie ist hier
standen von ihren Anfängen bis z
abschiedstnee
[Musik]
ihrer langen
Karriere der Film heißt i am a noise ist
natürlich viel viel mehr als das und
läuft ab heute in den deutschen Kinos
und jetzt die Frage an dieser Stelle was
läuft im Fernsehen nachher später läuft
hier noch unser heute journal Update und
zwar mit nasan GÖD gegen 0:30 in allen
einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter für die Jahreszeit
zu mild so geht es erst einmal weiter
hier kommt aus dem Westen milde Luft
aber auch viel Feuchtigkeit
dementsprechend gibt's Regen im Norden
und in der Mitte aber die Regenmengen
die halten sich tatsächlich in Grenzen
in der Nacht ist der Regen im Nordwesten
dann und dazu gibt's auch einige
Gewitter Richtung Nordsee auch ziemlich
viel Wind hier ist es stürmisch nach
südenin gibt's einzelne Schauer
Temperaturen sinken in der Nacht an den
Alpen auf 0° 5° Richtung vogland und 9°
z.B ganz im Westen dort ist es relativ
mild und morgen schwenkt die Front
Richtung Mitte kommt aber nicht ganz in
den Süden voran hier erst einmal
Sonnenschein ja und dieser Regen der
schleift sich hier über der Mitte dann
ein ziemlich viel Wind gibt's Richtung
NO Nordsee weiterhin hier weiterhin
stürmische Böhen aus südwestlichen
Richtungen bei höchsten Temperaturen von
7° Richtung östliche Mittelgebirge 11°
ganz im Westen und am mildesten noch
ganz im Südwesten bei
13° die nächsten Tage ja einige Schauer
gibt's am Samstag aber auch viel Sonne
z.B im Süden bei 6 bis 12° Silvester
kommt ein neues Regengebiet aus dem
Westen auf und dazu ist es an der
Nordsee wieder stürmisch bis 7 bis bei 7
bis 12° und Neujahr gibt's von
Nordwesten neuen Regen und immer noch
relativ mild einen schönen Abend